c'est quelque chose qu'on suivait de
près sans pour autant être capable de
prédire la catastrophe qui s'est
finalement produite
autre titre de cette édition en Chine
mystérieux virus de la même famille que
le sera ça déjà contaminé 45 personnes
un chiffre beaucoup plus important selon
des scientifiques le virus pourrait se
propager à l'étranger de 31 décembre
je vois arriver sur ma boîte mail une de
ses alertes qui nous dit quatre
personnes ayant fréquenté un marché à
Wahran en Chine se sont retrouvés
hospitalisés pour une pneumopathie
caractérisée comme atypique d'allure
virale qui n'était pas la grippe et là
il y avait plusieurs mots clés qui
étaient marcher pneumopathie atypique ça
n'est pas la grippe et la Chine qui nous
a évidemment rappelé ce qui s'était
passé en 2003 avec le coronavirus du
stras